The joe rogan experience.
You boy,
you fucked up.
Then I could get over is a,
and this video is how weird are dresses
that cross both of their vaginas just
out there in the breeze.
Strangest dresses that she's got on.
She's got this little station.
It's draped over the
opening of the vagina,
just so cleverly,
so clever.
Like the parts that we're going to show
is right up to the gateway of the vagina
and then from there there's
nothing but a breeze.
Nothing but a breeze and to
cross legs and this tiny,
the thinnest possible type of cloth
we can make the stiffness lightest.
Most Times seethrough you could see pubic
hair right through the fucking thing
that's there.
Hey man,
you're getting a little too
detailed and it's just weird.
It's just weird how women
are allowed to do that.
It's so rude.
No wonder why you alimony laws
are in the position they're in.
We're at a severe disadvantage
is by their attire.
They're there.
New fucking dangling,
a carrot there,
dangling the carrot.
It's rude.
I never realized that it's total
drying the chairs and move.
Not only that,
how about the fact they've got shoes on
that make their ass do something that it
never doesn't.
Real life you're leaning forward is
if you're just begging for someone to
fucking doggy style,
like all day long,
you're just accentuating your ass.
You're leaning forward.
Like you're just,
you're giving step one to a five step
process of doggy style and you're already
at step one everywhere you go.
Genius.
Why?
Why isn't the man who invented high heels?
Why is it that a household name
that that's the most genius thing?
Because you can get,
guys will spend,
I put myself in debt buying girls dinner
who looked that good and high heels and
then I then the heels come off and
they're back of your house and everything
else changes.
You're like,
aw man,
that's just somehow
that's a huge difference.
I mean I do see I'm totally different.
That doesn't do a damn thing to me.
Really doesn't do anything to me.
I don't get it at all.
I mean,
if a woman has beautiful legs,
the legs are beautiful and like
if she's barefoot is just as hot
blocks with confidence and heels,
not like those big stripper fuck
stiletto things like nights chair.
Nice,
nice high heels.
When you see a woman who
was like walks confidently,
what I'm saying?
It's like it.
Yeah,
it is definitely a debilitating,
yeah.
It's like a man who's really
good at the trap piece.
Save men.
Julia said it's like a man is
really good at the trapeze.
Wow.
What skill he's acquired.
Look at her.
Oh.
What I'm saying is that a woman can have
not such a great ass and legs it when
and if they had the right
heels you can get very fooled.
Wow.
Yeah.
It definitely accentuate,
things come off and you're like,
oh,
well that wasn't exactly what I like.
Lingerie doesn't do shit for me.
I mean,
I guess it does.
If it looks good,
it looks good.
I mean,
but if like,
you know,
is it necessary?
No,
no.
I noticed when a woman
dresses well and cool,
like some girls dress really
cool in an effortless way.
I find that very attractive.
You're a weird motherfucker.
That's why you're into fashion.
Yes.
I am turned to the fashion whatever
girls showed up at your house with velcro
shoes on and a fanny pack,
but she had a banging ass banger.
Yeah,
wouldn't really bother you.
Right me at all.
When you're talking about a
girl can be in a burlap sack.
I don't give a shit.
Forget that.
In moments when she was naked,
it's like,
guys,
I've always been the kind of
guy like my friends be like,
Nah,
I wouldn't do that,
but I couldn't get past her feet.
Shut the fuck up you baby.
There are some feet that
really will fuck you up.
She could have,
she could have hooves.
She's got a banging ass.
If there's an evolutionary
thing for that though,
if someone's got some
crazy fucked up feet,
you're like,
Hey,
am I going to have to carry you?
That's what I'm looking for.
Food is going to be a certain point in
time where you're not going to be able to
make it.
It's really funny you going,
I wonder if that's true.
It's 100% what it is.
Cause I do.
I also did be feet.
How can we like,
we're not about her elbows.
I like petite arched feet that I
think are an arched foot is very sexy.
A petite foot.
Really?
That's so weird.
Yeah.
That's not good.
I just like using a flat foot on a,
I like the foot of a woman
who couldn't go hiking.
A woman who's got some sturdiness tour.
Yeah,
you'd have to have a little tiny feet.
You fucking Weirdo.
He wants these chicks to be
like barely able to talk.
Hey Bro.
Excuse me sir.
He just slipped me into,
I can and see if you can't,
it's too high.
Can you,
do
they have to have a German accent?
I don't know why
that girl,
what's the ideal weight?
What's the ideal weight for me?
Another dimension.
If you weren't married,
what's the ideal way?
About 80 pounds.
No,
no,
no.
Okay.
It's a breeding thing I need,
I need about one 15 is good.
One 15 one 2015 but but athletic.
I like athletic.
I like broad shoulders,
small waist and a and
high insertion calves.
It's funny,
man.
The,
the,
the skirt thing,
it's a,
it's a very weird thing when you see them
walking down the street and especially
in Hollywood on Melrose,
you'll see people walking down the street
where their skirt and these are not
sluts.
I shouldn't even use that word.
Shouldn't slut shame.
It's really not nice.
Yeah,
and women who want to
have sex with people,
they're not slots know
enjoying their life.
The Lord,
I hate myself for using
that angel of the Lord.
What I should say,
stress for these are,
these are not prostitutes.
These are just girls like to dress in
style and sexy and that were in these
shorts that are just,
there's just a little
canopy over your vagina.
I never had that.
So much is dangling.
Right?
I mean,
right there you're talking about maybe
three inch hard to get work done,
maybe three inches.
And they have a skirt that like
they'll lowered part of their ass.
It's a normal thing to see the lower
part of a girl's ass and a skirt in
Hollywood.
Yeah.
It's a normal thing.
Exactly.
It's ridiculous.
It's,
it fucks the whole game
up and completely ruined.
Be Distracting.
It completely ruins our ability to form
rational thoughts and figure out what we
were talking about,
how important it is to keep your
mind on the right things in a way.
Some societies are like,
you know what?
All women are going to be completely
covered cause nobody's getting any fucking
work done.
Maybe that's where the burger came from.
We need to build a fucking pyramid,
goddammit.
We don't need to be staring
at my ass all day comedy.
These bitches,
we got work to do.
Yeah.
Cover.
I'm covering lab.
We got to build pyramids,
going to put rocks.
Nobody wanted to push push rods.
We just want to stare
at chickson ministerial.
We'll hook up eventually.
If you have enough attractive people in
the of the opposite sex in the same room
for long enough,
things are going to ask.
Yeah.
Even if you hung out in the same room,
it's exactly accurate.
They smell each other.
We're fucking Weirdos.